[inaudible]
great. Let's talk about consciousness
a little bit. I just had Sam Harris on.
We've,
we've talked about it quite extensively.
I think you have some
thoughts on consciousness,
the nature of consciousness.
Indeed. Yeah. I mean it's
probably to do this right,
we would need to agree on a definition.
I'm not sure that that's any definition
that we choose will immediately
antagonize some amount of your audience.
This is like defining div wedding.
This is like defining truth, which seems
to be tough these days. Yes, exactly. Um,
so maybe, maybe rather than that, um,
you are humans the only conscious
beings on this planet? I don't think so,
but we are the most conscious.
We are the most fully conscious and
we have better access to our own
consciousness obviously.
Then we have access to the consciousness
of say dolphins or elephants or other
apes or maybe wolves,
any of these long lived social organisms
with long childhoods and generational
overlap who lived sometimes with
three generations together at a time.
So this transmission of
cultural information,
organisms that have theory of mind and
can imagine can put themselves in the
other individual's position. And think,
what do they think is going on right now?
Even though I understand that that's
a different thing than what I think is
going on right now,
which we now know that certain
monkeys and apes exactly do that. Yes,
theory of mind. There's
a beautiful book, um,
called baboon metaphysics
by the husband and wife,
team Chaney and Seyfarth that basically
explores theory of mind and baboons. Uh,
and you know, it's not the only one. Um,
they're, they're not the only species,
but you know,
how do we as humans find our
consciousness best? You know, there,
there are ways that we can hack into
what is sometimes been called flow states
or, um, you know, that's, that's
the most common one. But you know,
we can do so through well,
through deep conversation, um,
through meditation,
through music,
some, sometimes through producing
it, but sometimes to experiencing,
especially live music,
dance for some people,
Hallucinogens, sex, sport, you know,
intense physical or physiological or
emotional experience in which we are just
moving with others usually. And you
know, there are those of us like myself,
you have a very strong introvert who
will find, so my deepest flow stays,
you know,
access to consciousness alone.
You're alone in the Amazon when I can
sit and watch monkeys and write that for
me. That's one of them. But sport is also,
so when I talked about this with Sam,
the way he was defining it,
which I think is sort of similar
to what you're saying here,
it strikes me as just like an extreme
ability to maintain presence in the moment
that that really sort of
when a basketball player,
so if we use the sport analogy like a
basketball her when they're the zone,
you know, and Jordan scores 20 points and
five minutes and he just, he goes, well,
everything I threw up
just went in like that.
They hit that level of consciousness
or for you to be outside enough out of
yourself to be able to write
in that perfect moment or,
or whatever it is that it,
oh,
it always seems about being present more
than anything else to me is a kind of,
um,
time stopping time stopping and
disappearing on you at the same time,
which I think is part of why Anthea,
Jen's hallucinate,
hallucinogens can kind of capture
that as well because they're,
the sense of time just disappearing
on you is, is remarkable. Um,
so you,
you both don't care about time and time
passes usually in ways that seem quicker
than you were expecting them to, uh, with,
with say sports or um, or
right. Meditation. I, yeah,
that's not one that I do, but, um, you
know, Sam has a lot to say about that.
Of course. Um, yeah,
I remember when I was doing mushrooms,
at least squares in college
aged somewhat consistently,
maybe every six months or something.
Um,
I would always want the clocks to
be covered. Yes. Because I hated it.
I hated the numbers are no
good. I did. I definitely did.
One trip like five hours in the mirror,
forget that.
But I always wanted the clocks to be
covered because the idea that time was
passing while I was in this state was,
was very scary to me.
That's scary. Or just, I just wanted
nothing to do with it. I guess.
Maybe it doesn't matter what
that distinction is, you know,
scary or just not interested.
Right. But, um, so it's,
it's very different.
The,
the kinds of consciousness enhancing
activities that we can engage in,
including hallucinogens
are very different.
If you're inside in a room like this
where you have no access to what is going
on climatologically or weather
wise outside, as opposed to if you,
if you are out and you can watch as the
sunsets and as the moon comes up and you
can think again, oh, right, it's
a, it's a, it's a waxing moon.
It'll be full in four days and um,
or you know,
or you're at a coast and you can watch
the tides and think about the shifting
time.
So for me,
thinking about time that is clearly being
brought as clearly being revealed by
the planet.
We're on as opposed to coming
at me through a clock is
more meaningful and I'm,
I'm willing to think
about time in that way,
but definitely not through clocks when
I'm, when I'm writing hallucinogen sport,
any of that.
Right.
And yet we have all of these devices
now that are men constantly talk to our
time that are meant to take our attention
that does he literally designed this
way?
Do you sense runs like that?
There's actually a digital assault on
consciousness because maybe that really
does explain so many of the other problems
we're having in society right now.
It's, it's one of the key pieces for sure.
And I think that phrase is brilliant.
A digital assault on consciousness.
This is something,
I'm Tristan Harris who I don't know,
but I bet him on the show. Yeah,
I'm talks talks about a lot
and you know, he, he's been,
he has been ringing the alarm bell for
years about the algorithms that are being
put into our devices that are,
that are creating addicts out of us.
But more broadly, your, you know, the
digital assault on consciousness is,
there's not,
there is,
it's increasingly hard to find a space
where you're just actually free and clear.
And this is,
you know,
this is part of what I do for myself and
what I used to do for my students was
take them to places,
not only that we're remote and
where they could explore nature,
but where there was no cell signal where
there was no internet. So, you know,
the deepest part of the Amazon that
I took students to, there's just,
there's no email, there's no internet,
there's no Wifi. We are, you know,
a plane ride over the Andes and then a
boat ride and then a truck ride and then
another five hours down a tributary of
the Amazon to a place with no roads,
no airstrips, nothing. And boy,
this time feel different and you need,
you're sleeping in little
cabins that are screened.
And so you wake up when the insects and
the birds and the monkeys wake up and
they start talking at you.
They're not talking to you,
they're talking to themselves.
But you getting a sense of the rhythms
of the planet that we're on can return
people I think to a real sense of self
and also to a sense of what they value,
what their passions are.
And this is a big thing that I
think is missing in many of the,
to return to what we were talking
about earlier. You know, the,
the far left activists,
the control left mostly I
think lack another passion.
And I've said before I,
you know,
the prediction I would make is that you
have very few rock climbers or skiers
among the radical left activists.
People who have something that they can
engage in that frees them from time and
devices from,
from a response to time.
I need to be here then or this my thing
just pinged me. I need to look at it, uh,
are better able to center themselves to,
to find their own
consciousness and discover who,
who they are and what they
want to be in the world.
What does that say about the
self? Do you think? To me.
There's something there about like if
you really believe in the self and your
and the individual and your
ability to overcome things,
you don't need all these external
processes to help define the world because
you're sort of defining it yourself.
I agree and I think I do think for me
self sufficiency is one of my highest
values personally and I have a,
I have a very hard time understanding
anyone who says Oh if you leave me on my
own I wouldn't know what to do.
Like I, I just don't get this.
I don't get why you would maybe want
to lefty thing. I'd be fine too.
I'm like what?
Why would,
why would you broadcast to the
world that you would be helpless?
This doesn't make any sense to me but,
and you know there plenty of situations
where I wouldn't know what to do and I
would know what to do in situations that
most people wouldn't just because of
where I've traveled and where I've lived.
But the idea that self
sufficiency required,
the idea that you want to
be self sufficient requires
a concept of self I think
is, is important here.
Yeah. Maybe just maybe that.
Yeah. And if you give that up, well then
boy you're, you're giving up a lot. You,
you give up so much.
And um,
the devices as,
as heroin,
as Tristan Harris has argued are addicting
us. It's no accident. We're, you know,
we, we should not view
ourselves actually as weak. We,
when we get addicted to the
things we should wean ourselves,
we should as much as possible
to provide ourselves zones,
periods of time when we have
no access to those things.
And so we are actually free and clear to
let our minds do what they will because
when, when we, uh, when they
have access to our brands,
they are designed to protect us.
So using,
using the discipline
that you're an expert in,
is it possible that we're in a unique
position right now because of technology
that our brains are actually evolving
now evolving or I guess devolving,
depending on which way you look at
it at an extraordinarily high pace or
something like that. You know, the,
the rate of change across almost
every sector in the economy,
in an human experience right now
is higher than it's ever been.
Could you say that about any
moment in history maybe. Um,
but the rate of change itself
is changing as well, right?
So that's the important
distinction, right? Um,
and what is going on with
technology is completely untested.
And so this is, this is a
place where, you know, why,
why am I so certain that
I'm still on the left,
even though most of the people who
say they're on the left publicly,
I don't have any interest in continuing
to talk to them because they don't seem
to be making any sense.
I look at systems that are involved,
that are, that are in stable state
because they've evolved over millions,
tens of millions,
hundreds of millions of years.
And my instinct is don't mess
with that until you really,
really understand what you're
doing. And so for instance, I,
unlike many scientists and
not feeding my children GMOs,
I give them and myself organic food
and when we meet, which we do a lot of,
I want that meat to
have been fed the grass,
if it's at the food of its ancestors,
what or what exactly is the harm?
We now know a little bit of this,
but 20 years ago if you asked me what's
the harm and feeding cows grands,
so I have no idea.
But I know that messing with a system
that was working is more likely to
interfere with something in that
animal then not why, you know,
why would you mess if you could not,
and of course there are economic
reasons to mess, but um, the,
the don't mess with systems that are
working until you really have a solid
understanding of what the, what
the effects are going to be. The,
the use of the precautionary principle
pretty widely is what puts me pretty far
on the left. But systems that we've
created that are evolutionary,
but people don't know that we need to
regulate in order to get them under
control because nuclear energy
isn't gonna regulate itself.
And habitat loss throughout most of the
world is not going to regulate itself.
So there are some problems that we've
created and that are bigger than
individuals can do anything about. And you
know, that's why I'm not a libertarian.
Right. And this is, this is where
I think we have a, I get it.
Like I don't know that if you just leave
everybody to do whatever the hell they
want all the time,
that everybody isn't going to be
doing all sorts of awful things.
I think generally the market does fix some
of that. But I get what you're saying.
Like these systems are I suppose
often precarious in nature too, right.
To the point where anything could be
tilted one way or the other and then we've
got bigger problems. Right? So how do
we, how do we fix some of this stuff?
How do we, how do we actually scale
this back? I mean, I get it, you know,
most of my audits we'll get, okay, well
we have to keep talking about it. Sure.
We have to wake more people up.
Sure.
But what can you do using the
knowledge you have and the,
and the study you've done?
I have less,
I have less insight right now at least
to answer in this amount of time, uh,
for the adult systems.
Um,
but I think I have a fair amount
of clarity on what we should do,
should be doing with children
and with parenting. We're really,
really not doing a,
which is when you say the adult systems,
you mean like economic systems
and, and, and more specifically,
how do you get adults who are already,
who they are to behave differently?
Um, it's, it's less clear to me what,
what we can do and so we'll show
them for the purpose of yes. Yes.
Also, also, it's true that I have, um,
that I'm not going to wade into a,
for instance,
what we should do about our
economic system here. Now with you.
I might do it later, but
yeah, it's like, okay. Um, but
with regard to, for instance,
you know, most, most people I think, I've
never thought about what childhood is.
And if you don't have children
yourself and you're an adult, okay,
maybe you don't have to,
maybe it doesn't matter.
Like maybe it just doesn't matter to you.
But if you're a parent,
you need to think about why it is that
we have literally the longest childhood
relative to lifespan of any organism
on the planet. This is a feature.
This is a way for us to learn how to
become humans. We are not, and this,
this is a point that Brett has made
very often. We're not playing slates,
but we are the blankets, slates of
any organisms on the planet. We,
we are more software than hardware.
And so what we're doing for these first,
I don't know,
11 to 25 years of our lives
right now into the forties.
I think it depends, but
depending on culture, you know,
when do you start calling
yourself an adult? And then, um,
what we're doing is learning how to be
human and we're learning how to be human
by direct X.
We're supposed to be learning how
to be human through instruction,
direct instruction by our parents,
through observing our parents,
through observing our siblings,
through interacting with,
including fighting with our siblings
and having them smack us down both
sometimes, literally, but
definitely metaphorically
when we do stupid things. And,
um,
better yet if our parents have lots of
adult friends around and they have lots
of kids and there's a whole mess of
humanity that we are learning from.
And then we're also in that very long
developmental period supposed to be
learning from direct physical
experience of the world.
So the example I like to go
to here is um, you know, the,
the roadrunner cartoons when Wiley
Coyote scoots is way off a cliff and he
doesn't fall until he realizes there's
nothing below him. It's funny, right?
Like it's really funny.
But of course it's funny because we know
the gravity doesn't really work that
way.
Right?
Increasingly I suspect that a
lot of kids and now into the,
and some of the younger
millennials kind of aren't sure,
like they were protected so much by
their helicopter parents and they were
behind screens rather than
having real experience.
And to the extent that they played sport,
it was totally regulated and overseen
by adults and they didn't have any free
time to go and get themselves into
trouble and maybe even like burn something
down or hurt themselves or break an arm
or whatever it is and learn from it that
they arrive at the cusp of what
should have been adulthood.
Totally unclear on what
that supposed to mean.
Does this absolutely to you because as
I'm hearing you say that this is the bell
going off in my head,
man,
I've been on a tour where Peter
soon for the last six weeks,
everything that you just said there
is basically what he is saying.
He is trying to, I sent that what he's
trying to do at the most personal level.
Yeah.
He talks about society as a whole,
but at the most personal level
he's trying to retool young people.
It's not even retool.
He's trying to give them the tools in
the first place that they clearly should
have gotten before.
So that's what's so fascinating to me
because it's like how did this happen?
Right? How did, how did this happen?
And, you know, we can point to,
we can point to pharmaceuticals being
given to kids to make boys less boy alike
and to some degree to make girls
last girl like, you know, give great,
let's give speed to boys. So they'll
serve and face forward and learn what.
So they'll calm down, calm down
and not do rough and tumble play.
And I mean that's insane.
And at the same time let's
give antianxiety meds to
girls and Ssri wise and um,
and you know, just, just
the model of schooling is
ridiculous. You know, we have,
we have schools that have gotten rid of
recess because recess is dangerous and
everyone who's ever been in school,
even if like me,
you happen to have been a good fit for
the model of schools that you were in,
which I think is pretty rare,
actually knows that you also need to
have time to get out there and play and
move your body and experience it and
not have it being overseen by some adult
who's decided in advance. What isn't,
is not safe for you to experience.
So know one of the things I used to say
to my students in advance, you know,
I did a lot of team building and like
actual team building and planning with
them in advance of these
lung study abroad trips.
We would have spent weeks together on
campus in advance of going on these trips.
Um,
but what I wanted to do before we
left was established with them.
What's your relationship with risk?
How do you, how do you view yourself,
your relationship with risk?
And we would do this in round like,
and I would answer the question too
and you know, I would say to them,
actually I happen to love risk.
I will,
I am the leader on this trip
but I will keep all of you safe.
But then I'm going to go
do things and you know,
I am going to walk alone in the forest a
lot and do things because it happens to
be one of the ways that I
find my consciousness that I,
that I find my truest self. And I don't
expect any of you to do that also,
but you need to be comfortable with the
fact that your leader is going to be
doing that sort of thing.
And one of the other things that we
were talking about was, you know,
what's your relationship with comfort?
Or you're going to be uncomfortable.
You're gonna have to, you know,
just because you can say in advance,
you're okay with the bugs and the mud
and the not having a phone doesn't mean
you actually will be when
you're faced with it. Uh,
but maybe most important is we are going
to leave ourselves open to serendipity.
I cannot tell you everything that we're
going to do or learn on this trip.
If I could,
what would be the point of going,
we're going to go and some interesting
things are gonna happen. I've,
I've had a couple of near
death experiences on these
trips. I didn't want them.
I didn't, you know, I, I, and you know, I,
I was always been a learning experience
where there's a learning experience and
frankly on the, on, on
the most recent one on a,
on a boat in the Galapagos with eight
students in which the only thing that
didn't survive was the boat. But it
was, it was really touch and go. I mean,
I really did almost die.
Those eight students and I are friends
for life. Right. You know, there's,
there's some of them that I'm
not an active contact with,
but I know where they are and that,
you know,
that bonds you and no,
I'm not going to pitch a trip with Andy
might die. That's not what the goal is.
But the idea that it could happen and
you should have the tools on board,
the physical tools, the psychological
tools, the emotional tools,
intellectual tools to figure out in real
time as your boat is being flipped by a
15 foot wave and now you're
trapped under it. What do you do?
Was that a uniquely
Evergreen type of teaching?
Was that something that
you and Brett really,
that was a unique name there me kind
of teaching. And then this last trip,
Brett was there with me as
well. There was, there was
a way in which I think what,
you know what I said about
childhood, which I, you know,
my interest originally and evolution
was about the evolution of parental care
and territoriality and social
systems and sexual selection.
And long before I ever had kids,
my cell phone before I wanted kids,
but I thought no one spread.
And I did have kids and I'm watching
these amazing creatures began to grow up.
Okay,
let's think then about what,
what is the best way to do this?
And we could put them a little boxes and
make absolutely sure that they survive
till the age of 18 and then we opened up
the boxes and we let them out and they
have basically no chance at being adults
or even of knowing how to be adults or
we could expose them to ever greater risk.
Having first made absolutely sure that
they know that they are loved and that we
have their backs and that we will do
anything to come in and get them and to
protect them if we can,
but that they are going to start going
out into the world pretty early. You know,
biking it too.
And you know,
we took them to the Amazon at seven and
nine the first time and young something
could've gone wrong and I don't know,
I've known parents who lost kids and
I don't know how you survive that,
but you need to be willing to take risks
such that when your kids do hit 18 or
20 or whatever,
you know that they're actually
already on their way to being adults.
And that is going to require backing
off and letting them do some of their
learning on their own and knowing that
that's going to result in some harm
coming to them and it's
going to be physical harm.
It's going to be psychological harm,
it's going to be intellectual harm.
But frankly,
the,
the lack of any kind of harm that a lot
of kids are experiencing is part of why
they're now saying speech is
violence. Yeah. Right. I mean that's,
that's part of how we get there
is some of this an extension of
the success of the West in a way.
Because if you take the,
this set of kids who however old they are,
let's say we go from,
although now there's a lot of
studies that are showing that young,
the generation younger than millennials
is actually leaning more conservative.
But let's say we take 16 to 30 roughly.
Yeah.
So generation y ish,
but you see that most of their parents
were baby boomers who were the most
successful, at least financially
generation ever. Most of the baby boomers,
parents all went to war and right.
You know,
live through depression
and all sorts of stuff,
but that because the baby
boomer is basically where
the biggest middleclass and
because there was such upward mobility,
they added so well,
they kinda got their eye off the ball,
started focusing on things
that didn't matter as much,
protecting kids from things that a kid
would have used to have to have done.
And that is sort of what led us here.
So it's almost like an economic
backing for what ended up happening
psychologically.
Yeah. I think, I think
that's apt. You know,
there's so many things
feeding into this and yes,
the wealth of America Post World War II,
uh,
and the fact that those are most
of the parents of the generation,
that seems the most confused. I think
definitely there's a causal link there.
Yeah. And then you toss into the
Internet and you toss on the Internet,
right. Um, which, you know,
we can't go back obviously.
Uh,
but,
but we need to understand that it's an
evolutionary system and then it's going
to run away from us and that we are all
prone to be addicted to dopamine hits.
We're going to seek the quick,
quick likes rather than,
you know, even even. Okay. So take
internet out of the picture for a moment.
If you don't know what you do for physical
activity, I bike you play basketball.
Okay. So maybe with basketball it's
going to be different. Uh, for me,
I like video games too. Is that
better? No, that's probably,
probably probably the opposite.
But,
so I used to play a lot of
ultimate frisbee and you
could like anytime there was
a pickup game, like I would, I,
I'm, I'm there. I was playing five,
six times a week for awhile.
Um,
and then I ruptured my Achilles tendon
playing on an Oregon beach with students
a few years ago. I'm not doing
that anymore. Um, but biking,
which I love and I find meditative,
I have a very hard time convincing myself
to get on my bike even though while
I'm doing it, I love
it. And after I do it,
I feel better and I'm more productive
and a more creative and I just am,
you know,
more in love with life,
but it's a pain in the ass and it's a
little bit physically uncomfortable.
And you know, all of
these things are true. We,
we prioritize the pleasure of now
over even something that for me,
I know not, it's not even that I'm
going to feel better after I did it.
I actually love the activity itself,
but getting over that sort of
activation energy to do the thing.
And I suspect that sport, like actual
team sports is a little bit different,
a little different. Like you're ready
to go. You ready to go? Like, oh,
people are there, I'm ready. I'll like,
let's, let's do it. Going to the gym,
I would like into that.
Like I know that when I work out,
I like doing it and I feel great after,
but it's like, oh, I gotta get in my car,
I got to drive over there and I
got a bark, or blah, blah, blah.
It feels like a chore, but yet,
you know, it's good. And yet,
so we're always fighting our nature
sort of. We are. No, exactly.
We're always fighting or nature and it
shouldn't surprise us that we're going to
need to fight our nature with regard
to responding to the Internet and
responding to,
especially especially the little computers
we carry around in our pockets and
you know,
learning to restrict our access to
those training ourselves to restrict our
access to those.
And I think anyone with the ability to
train themselves to meditate or to do
anything on a regular basis should,
should be able to train themselves that
same way with regard to devices. Yeah.
All right,
well we've done about an hour here and
I am going to demand that you come back
because I know,
I know we can do way more
of this unfortunately just
because my schedule is so
nuts at the moment. We,
we have to kind of stuff.
But can you give me one more thing that
you're just really excited about right
now that you've been thinking about or
working on or anything else that's really
just giving you a little bit,
uh,
a little bit of juice at the moment while
you're in this interesting space for
yourself? No. Um, there are a number
of things I guess. Um, there's a,
there's a piece I wrote a number of years
ago that is supposed to be out in the
literary magazine just about now,
ash about haven't been mugged
at knife point and Quito,
one of these on one of these
study abroad trips. Um,
which prompt and I was with
three students, Quito, the
capital of Ecuador. Okay.
So it was,
it was the very,
it was before the first day of one
of my six weeks study abroad trips.
I was a 20 students just made,
Brett wasn't there on this one. Um,
and the experience in
which, you know, we've been,
we've been to get the three students
that I have been together all day.
We come to the top of the stairs
and suddenly two guys with,
with knives run around the corner and
pin me and my female student up against a
wall and do this sort of knife dance
in front of us and then relieve.
I didn't have anything on me because I
know how to walk around Latin American
cities and one of my students didn't.
But two of my students had all
of their stuff taken off them,
including this really nice DSLR
that that Michelle my student had.
And
they run off.
And the next thing I realize I am on
one of these guys in the middle of the
street pulling on the backpack. He's
stolen from another one of my students.
Another one of my students has
chased down the other guy. Wow.
And thought,
how did that happen and why is
everything now so loud and so colorful?
And I thought back immediately thought,
wow,
the entire experience that I just had
was somehow in black and white and was
without sound.
And so,
I mean it's an interesting
long story that,
that I basically explored in
this essay by going into doing,
doing a dive into the literature
on the nature of memory,
on the nature of sensory memory in
particular and what it is that we can and
cannot perceive in the moment,
what our brands take in,
why time seems to slow down.
So just to go back to our
earlier conversation about time,
why tea time seems to slow
down in periods of intensity.
It's not that it time slows down,
but basically our frame rate increases
and not only our frame rate increases but
the amount that we remember and you know,
move into short term memory.
And then in this case into longterm
memory increases. So this is,
this is one of the things that I've been
thinking about lately is sort of how,
how memory and the senses and in fact
how all of us are a little bit of
synesthesia. It's are experiencing
our world in ways that,
that we don't usually have language for.
Now that it was the purpose of the story.
But how did this all end? It ended.
We got, we got the stuff back. Wow.
We got the stuff back and
as soon as the student,
Jeremy and I give [inaudible] Tracy
these guys and got the stuff back,
then the police showed up.
Then the pleaser got blurred up from
the island and the whole watching I,
it was, it was remarkable actually. It was
totally, there was no one on this walk.
We'd send no one. These two guys
run up to us, Mug us, run off,
we give chase, and then the
entire neighborhood comes alive.
Suddenly there were hundreds of
people there like,
where were you guys there?
There's some sort of study
to be done on that. Well,
I'm sure they've done studies on that.
You know,
when people see the bad thing happening,
but nobody calls the police and
all that kinda stuff. Well, listen,
it's been an absolute pleasure.
I'm so glad that we finally got to do
this in person and we will do it again.
And you guys can follow Heather on the
Twitter. She does tweet a decent amount,
but not a unhealthy addicted amount.
I would say it's at Heather.
He hiding.